man you guys came to play everybody dude
all right Mikey T how are you
tell me this guy's a cop dude
I don't know I don't like his vibes
yeah I don't know you you answered that
like we just pulled you over a DUI stop
doing good officer how are you yeah I
know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just so you know I'm recording it
I do not consent to search and seizure
which by the way those videos are all
right to watch
I assume you did good in the SATs what'd
you
get
that's pretty good that's good [ __ ] all
right I think
yeah
is that a 32 or something
36 maybe it's not that good
what'd you get your degree in
okay pretty good what'd you have for
breakfast
all in the [ __ ] Master Cleanse here
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] not one biscuits and gravy or
nothing
what'd your parents do
okay
okay
not a doctor I picked that up by works
at a hospital
no son of a doctor says oh my parents uh
yeah they work at the hospital
[Laughter]
not the son of a neurologist
Mike's question is it garbage that your
family thought that milkshakes were
healthy because they had milk in them
definitely not a doctor
Bradley works in the cafeteria though
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] when would they give them to
give them to you milkshakes halftime of
the soccer game
before basketball tryouts
shocker he didn't make the team
he did take a nap on the foul line
coach I'm sleepy
no [ __ ] you still like a nice milkshake
from time to time Mike because you look
I can't really see from here but you
look like you're a pretty in shape guy
283 at four years old did you say
I was
fighting weight
the best years of his life
I call it my Prime
[Applause]
okay how much weight have you lost
because all you did was cut out the
milkshakes
fantastic case you're in good I got good
news for you big guy
all right giving up my milkshakes
I'm gonna have to take my foot God damn
it
what was your favorite flavor of
milkshake
she's got a real serial killer vibe
he's gonna be wearing a Foley suit later
for Mikey t one time yeah
man I want a [ __ ] milkshake man I
just forgot about that inhaler street
fight question too
I just saw it again that's crazy dude
you two get into a fighty chugs of
milkshake
all right we gotta do one more then we
gotta get out of here you guys have been
[ __ ] insane give yourselves a round
of applause one time
all right
this one's from Josh B
ever eaten the free breakfast at a hotel
you've never been a guest of
all right
you guys have been [ __ ] awesome you
guys are absolutely amazing we'll be out
on the side we want to meet all you guys
grab a picture thank you so much thank
you so much